to my surprise a great game to discuss
after that ravens browns game monday
night
for the ages it raises the bar and then
you see the next game on the schedule is
chargers raiders
and the bar lowers but they delivered
even though it was a game without a ton
of consequences
the raiders were playing for something
the chargers weren't and the chargers
ended up playing like the team that was
playing for something
the 30-27 overtime victory we'll break
that down
over the remainder of this segment big
cap but i tell you what my
big takeaway more than anything else was
that marcus mariota
really showed up well played well it's a
shame it didn't work out for the raiders
not in the sarcastic that's a shame way
it is a shame because
once derek carr pulled up with the groin
injury and it was obvious he wasn't
going to be back
you know anybody that's ever pulled a
groin a hamstring like that it doesn't
immediately go away it's not something
you can go back and get an iv for like
lamar jackson on monday night you're
done it's over
mariota gets thrust into action and he
looked as good as he ever has
yeah he he he did look fantastic you're
absolutely right that is the biggest
takeaway
that uh mariota should get a shot at a
starting job going into next year just
based on this game alone
and coming in in a pinch and looking
good
but outside of mariota i know you want
to talk about it
mike i know you want to talk about how
bad the coaching was
i know you want to talk about anthony
lynn but before we talk about anthony
lynn
i know you really want to talk about the
fact
that in the last six years john gruden
is now 40 and 61 as a head coach
no coach would ever survive that i don't
understand what's going on this is
the second year in a row where the
raiders have collapsed down the stretch
year one was a total rebuild so so four
wins
that's fine you can excuse that year two
looked like they were building something
year three
they have that momentum they they i i've
said this
on pretty much every show i've done i've
never seen a team
basically win a super bowl by losing a
sunday night football game
and the raiders lost that game to the
chiefs
what it was a month ago and they
basically
said the whole world said watch out for
the raiders the raiders have now beaten
the chiefs and taking them to the
last minute and making homes go 90 yards
to beat them
watch out for the for the raiders they
are really really good
what have they done since they got
absolutely punked by the
the falcons they barely beat a winless
jets team
they get punked by the cults and they
lose in a must-win game
on thursday night football against
anthony lynn who has done
everything possible to lose these games
like he tried
to lose this game 15 different times
and the raiders wouldn't let them one of
the things that i realized i don't miss
about not having you on as regularly as
we have in the past is i can't tell
whether or not you're trolling me
no i'm being serious i'm because
yesterday i
let me say this yesterday as sims and i
were
stumbling through a preview of the game
i kind of tripped over this idea that
you know if there was any other coach
but john gruden
performing the way that his team has the
last three years we'd at least be
saying gee i wonder if he'll be fired
when the season's over
with gruden it doesn't even come up yeah
no it doesn't come up
and it's the way the raiders have had
these last two seasons go
where yes the defense is flawed but
guess what john gruden has a
decent say in how the roster is built
with mike mayok
so that that is on his resume as well
but when you have a team that looks like
a playoff team for half the season
and then completely falls apart in
december and january when winning
football is played
it's like the old belichick belichick
whatever he says like the
december after thanksgiving that's when
real football is played that's when you
find out
what your team is well if that's when
you find out what your team is
john gruden has been horrendous as a
head coach
well he hasn't won a playoff game since
winning super bowl 37 18 years ago and i
know he didn't coach for nine years of
that window
but the the the performance
hasn't matched the mystique there's a
little rex ryan or maybe a lot of rex
ryan and john gruden he's good on tv he
talks a good game he's fun
to watch and it makes raiders fans more
than anything else
excuse the fact that the results aren't
there they're just so happy that he's
the coach
they don't care what the results are and
i feel like mark davis the owner of the
team
has the same attitude he's just thrilled
that john gruden this
cool guy john gruden is his head coach
that we're not going to worry about how
many games we win we're not going to
worry about
spending way too much money on offense
on acquisitions that
for the most part didn't work and not
spending enough money on the defense and
it's ultimately john gruden that's
controlling
that roster he ran off reggie mckenzie
after one year who did a good job
putting together a team that went 12-4
in 2016 and made it to the playoffs
and after one year with gruden
mckenzie's kicked to the curb gruden
wants someone in there
that basically is going to give gruden
the guys he wants it's gruden making
those final decisions with mike mayhawk
setting the table
and if i'm mike mayok at some point i
start looking over my shoulder because
it looks like gruden is in blame someone
other than me mode after
firing a defensive coordinator on sunday
on a short week which made no sense and
based on giving up 30 points last night
still makes no sense i know they had a
bunch of guys injured but you know other
teams say injuries aren't an excuse
other teams win with guys
replacing players who are either on the
covet 19 reserve list or unable to play
due to injury and they perform at a
standard that is expected of them
so it just feels like this is
what it's going to be and i don't know
what they need to do
in this offseason or any off season to
change it and at some point it may start
with the quarterback i don't know you
know i i'm not sure i can be
objective with derek carr because i i
still don't get it
but you know i know he's had moments and
i was starting to
sign on i was starting to buy in i mean
they beat the saints and the chiefs this
year
the top two teams in the league
arguably the saints have fallen off
after losing but
i i don't get it when they lose these
other games that they should win
but that's the thing mike is it john
gruden actually has done a good job with
derek carr so
he has done good a good job in the
quarterback position and getting the
most out of derek carr i think derek
carr
this year has been playing at or near
his ceiling as a quarterback
so that one you check that mark and you
say okay john gruden you've done that
everything else is a disaster and
everything else has
has fallen apart late in the season two
years in a row
and you're right i think it just is what
it is i don't think that
john gruden is going anywhere i know
mark davis doesn't want to fire him
i know that it gives the raiders some
type of relevancy
in that respect where you have almost a
celebrity head coach and john gruden
and we know john gruden's good in in the
meetings you know you know he's good
talking to the press
so he's always going to have those guys
on his side but
if we're sitting here next year a year
from now and we're having the exact same
conversation
no other coach would survive that and i
think john gruden will
well and part of it is and we don't know
the details of the contract all we know
is 10 years 100 million dollars that's
what was leaked out there
when he took the job three years ago we
don't know how much that's guaranteed we
don't know how it's structured it's just
10 years 100 million sounds really good
but at some point in that contract i
believe we get to a juncture where the
guaranteed money dissipates there may
not be any at all on the back end
you still have to have an owner that is
motivated to move on
and then go hire someone else and mark
davis is perfectly content and still is
not just content
thrilled that john gruden is the coach
of the team and believes that
that brighter days are always ahead and
this is where i
respect and admire what john gruden has
done
in an industry that is as cutthroat and
demanding and results driven as
any in the world he he's found a way
to avoid the same degree of scrutiny
that applies to everyone else it's
fascinating and it's great work if you
can get it
and he just keeps showing up year after
year and like you said if we're having
this conversation next year
any other coach would be fired or close
to it and for gruden it's gonna be well
what are we gonna do to try
to get a better outcome next year even
though we've got four years of spinning
our wheels in the mud
so the theory that i've always uh
prescribed to
and that we've talked about on pardon my
take often is that
uh if you look at him sideways john
gruden and mark davis kind of look
like twins so mark davis uh
you know john gruden has figured out the
one owner in the nfl where he can get
hired and when
that owner looks him in the eyes the
owner is looking at a better version of
himself
it's hard to fire a better looking
version of yourself
i think that's what's going on here mike
interesting theory i i think i've heard
that one before from you
and uh look what when it makes sense
this is what when when you befriend
someone that you may have to fire
someday you become less likely to fire
them
for reasons that you would otherwise
fire someone
that's why there needs to be a healthy
distance between nfl owner
and nfl coach just like there's a
healthy distance between nfl coach
and nfl player it's inevitable as john
gruden always said
you've either been fired or you're going
to be fired he's the founder of the
fired
football coaches association and that's
what makes this so compelling
he's found a way to avoid having to
worry about getting fired and
this may be one of the reasons why
they're not as good
as they need to be one of the arguments
always made about mike mccarthy in green
bay
because there isn't an owner there a
traditional owner
publicly owned team there isn't that
constant fear
that on any given day the owner can say
i've had enough
until you do better or unless you do
better i've had enough and you're gone
and i feel like you've taken that
element off the table in las vegas
with john gruden by having an owner who
is not going to fire him
uh barring a total and complete
collapse and they'd have to be 2 and 14
for multiple years and
even then mark davis would be weeping
on his way to the meeting with john
gruden to
tell him it's over it would be the
equivalent of taking
you know the dog on the last ride to the
country that's what it would be like
for mark davis so he's not going to do
it and john gruden's not going to be
scrutinized
at the same level anyone else would be
and that's just the way it is
and and you know a lot of raiders fans
are fine with it i got a lot of hostile
emails yesterday
that i'd love to be able to read word
for word but every other word would be a
bleep
that they're they're they're in the
personality cult we're fine with it john
gruden's the coach doesn't
doesn't the attitude is it doesn't
matter if we're winning a losing we want
john gruden to be our coach
how much of that do you think is uh that
it's objectively cool to wear
raiders gear so even when they're bad
like
repping the raiders is a cool thing to
do
oh i'm serious like that's those things
matter like those things play into
being okay with bad football year in and
year out
if you have a redeeming quality of like
hey guess what we're still the silver
and black
and it's still the coolest like color
scheme and probably the nfl
and you still have the autumn wind as a
pirate all these things when you add
them up
we can we can take a few years of losing
football if we can
you know wear this hat with pride and
and
have you know i guess they don't have
oakland anymore but
this new stadium in las vegas and this
cool factor
depends on what hat you wear last night
john did have
oakland he said he said yeah that
tricked him somebody fooled him
he was wearing an oakland raiders hat
last night before he switched to las
vegas raiders but
you know there's similarity between the
raiders and the cowboys i mean the
cowboys
haven't been to a conference
championship game since 1995 and until
this year
they had still managed to have a great
following i mean this year they get
flexed out of prime time for the browns
and the giants i think maybe the shine's
coming off the star
but for the raiders they've got one
playoff appearance since
the super bowl appearance in 2002 when
they got shredded by john gruden that
may be one of the reasons why they're
just thrilled to have john gruden they
experience those
four hours on a morning or an on a
morning it is morning but there go the
lights on on a late afternoon
would you do you have like the clapper
do you wave your arms and the lights
come on
no i mean that's part of my studio yeah
they're most
motion censored i guess i wasn't moving
enough so i'll just
i'll remind myself to move every now and
then
the the the anyway the raiders fans that
saw john gruden and the buccaneers
dismantle a great raiders team
maybe that memory still resonates and
like this we want this guy
they were seething the whole time how
did we ever let this guy go
we man if we could only get him back as
our head coach it took 17 years
but they got him back as their head
coach and there's no way they're going
to let him go after only three years
because what happened the last time he
left he went somewhere else and he beat
us in the super bowl
do you know what it kind of reminds me
of mike it reminds me of some of the
quote-unquote blue blood college
football programs that are kind of
holding on to the past
and thinking that things will return to
how they were
and everyone who's looking around saying
like wait no they aren't
like you're it's not it's not going back
to what it was
unless something's you know really
shifts here
and i that's what i think about when i
think about the raiders and the cowboys
and you're right like
the history matters uh to the fans
they can kind of hang their hat on that
and that probably
allows for the frustration of losing
to be tempered a little bit if we're
just being totally honest
if you can pop in a dvd and watch the
90s
like this happens sometimes because i i
i have friends
or i don't really have friends but i
know people who are
uh bears friends that just hold on to
1985. i'm not old enough
to you know i was i was one years old
but there are
certain people in different fan bases
where they look back to the history and
they're like well
you know we were at one point the best
it's like but look at what's happened
recently the last 20 years
you haven't done anything so um can we
talk real quick about the other coach in
this game
sure anthony lin has
uh i from from my perspective he is now
the funniest coach in the nfl
funny how funny how what are you talking
about
yeah is he a clown i think we lost andy
reid
the the the when he won a super bowl we
lost the jokes we could make about clock
management
anthony lynn has has stepped up to the
plate
and uh done a great service to america
to be the coach that we can now make fun
of when he panics
i've never seen a coach do what he did
last night in regulation where
his uh kicker misses a kick they get the
interception
he then plays for three points when his
passing game did you know that justin
herbert only had one pass
in the last like 18 minutes of
regulation it's insane
their passing game was working all night
he run it three times or they run it
twice and then they have a bad sack
and then he iced his own kicker mike he
iced his own kicker
i just froze i just froze because i got
so upset about that
he iced his own kicker mike well and
we've seen that before with jason
garrett although i think jason garrett
had a semi-plausible explanation
anthony lynn did not and that's the
thing when michael badgley misses
the shorter field goal not not that they
should have gone for it on fourth down
it was just a bad circumstance to even
set it up that way you get a gift
it was kind of a fluky throw yes marcus
mariota threw it behind
the receiver i think i can't remember
who the receiver was
threw it behind him a little bit bounced
off his hand chris harris jr is there to
pick it off in stride and off he goes
with it
completely flips the field in one play
at the worst possible time for the
raiders
and there's no killer instinct there
here's where i have to give
anthony lynn and the chargers some
credit though in overtime we saw
killer instinct we saw the throws down
the field
we saw that we're not going to play for
a tie here we'd rather lose than ty
and the only way to come out here with a
victory is to get the ball down the
field
maybe it was good that the raiders
uh took the field goal right because
then it kept the charges from trying to
take a field goal mike we also saw
anthony lynn try to get his franchise
quarterback killed
in back-to-back plays where they tried
to to do a qb sneak
not from the inch line that was a full
yard that was crazy that he did that
two times in a row justin herbert
fumbles the first time
bass almost fumbles a second time so
let's see
there was one big pass play that got him
down there okay well they got down there
and then yeah before that they did
student body right with justin herbert
trying to run the old green bay gym tail
or sweep
yes exactly so let's let's pump the
brakes they got a nice
they got a nice uh pass interference
call to get them
you know to the 50-yard line or that
might have even been in regulation
but they had one big play over time yeah
so they had one big play in overtime
a penalty and then they tried to get
justin herbert killed
three plays in a row which was
stupefying
so i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna push
back a little bit and say that he had a
great overtime
the the the throw from justin herbert
maybe that's the punishment for under
throwing it when it could have been the
walk off there since you under through
it you have to be the one to try to
finish off the drive it's on you so
you're going to run it every time and it
ultimately did work out
and you know the holy roller rule
that played out was fascinating because
those are the two teams and this was
way before your time it was during my
time as a kid
the holy roller phenomenon and we posted
a link on our twitter page
to the video of the original holy roller
it's obvious that there was some
intentional accidental kicking of the
football toward the end zone
in the hopes that it would be recovered
in the end zone by a raider
that happened last night and i was
stunned that no one remembered
that number one it's the holy roller
roll and number two it was those two
teams
and uh there was that flash of oh my
gosh the
chargers have won the game in this crazy
way but yeah you can't
you can't recover the fumble farther
down the field in that moment we've
known that for years because of the holy
roller
but that was a nice little flash of
drama right before justin herbert got
the ball over the top and for a second
there until they showed the replay
i thought maybe he didn't get the ball
in maybe the ball came out maybe the
raiders recovered it maybe the game was
over there but it was clear that he got
the ball
over the top the third try the third
time he got thrown into a mass of bodies
and i i'll agree with you reluctantly
i'm gonna be nice it's been a while
since you've been on
the the play calling down near the goal
line even though it worked ultimately it
probably wasn't the best way to keep
your quarterback healthy going into his
first nfl offseason
yes okay so one point for me already uh
but
i guess that and the charges do have a
history the chargers do have a history
in late regular season meaningless games
getting their quarterback
seriously injured before he goes on to
become one of the great quarterbacks of
all times with the new orleans saints
yes right so i you know this game was
not great
but i think the bad coaching made it
great in an enter in an entertaining way
uh so i'll thank both anthony lynn and
john gruden for that i i know we've been
hard on them for the first 20 minutes of
the show
but thank you for sending us off uh
with an entertaining game if not
stupefying
if not there's there's a level where you
know i love mac football
uh on tuesday and wednesday nights and
you know like when bowling green plays
ball state
when i start getting the tweets saying
this is a mac game
that's when you know that it it's kind
of chaos
has reigned supreme and nothing makes
sense
and that was what anthony lynn and john
gruden were able to accomplish last
night
to me it was all encapsulated in the
moment at the end of regulation when the
raiders send out daniel carlson for a
65-yard field goal
and they can't work out the snap and the
hold right yeah like
because you're thinking the whole time
why are they doing this this isn't going
to end well and i think if i'm a raiders
fan i'm relieved by the fact that that
kick didn't actually happen because low
trajectory
may have been blocked may have been
returned for a touchdown
and then we may not have had overtime
but you know i i
i was so just excited to watch another
football game after that
that game on monday night and and as it
was unfolding i was kind of reluctantly
watching well it's on tv it's my job
it's like i'm really not into this game
but as the game went on and i think the
moment derek carr got injured and marcus
mariota came in and instantly looked
good
that's when i got very intrigued by
because your first thought is if you
lose your starting quarterback
unexpectedly
your chances of winning the game plummet
but
they invested in marcus mariota seven
and a half million this year
he's due to make 10 million next year
and derek carr is making 19.5 million
and
i i i don't know do the raiders have a
decision to make between the two if they
don't
you're not going to keep mariota at 10
million i don't know if you trade him
maybe you got some trade leverage now
because he looks so good but
you know and i understand that if he
plays week in and week out he's
eventually going to get banged up and
he's not going to be as good as he was
last night when he was fresh
but if you can keep the guy healthy he's
got the potential to be
a good starting quarterback in the nfl
yeah
i agree i agree it's um it's interesting
that when you go back to that draft
class and it's like you know jameis
winston and marcus mariota
both of them backups this year both i
would say
should be starters like i think that
they are if you had to list it
i would i would make the argument that
marcus mariota and jameis winston are
somewhere in the top 32 quarterbacks in
the world
so it's interesting to see where both
these guys will end up
and will they get another shot at his
starting job i think marcus mariota kind
of proved that last night
let's hear some of the praise from last
night from various raiders regarding the
unexpected performance of mark marcus
mariota and the unexpectedly
good showing that he had here it is
marcus came in and did a great job and
um
really proud of him i think that just
kind of puts an exclamation point on why
we signed him and
i just wish we could have won the game
for him well he made the defense play
honest
uh the the ends couldn't come chase us
down like they did last game we played
them
um they had to play their gaps and play
their responsibilities
so we just made them play on it i feel
like marcus played great i feel like
the way marcus comes to practice every
day has a good attitude and
plays hard and uh i feel like it was no
surprise to see him play the way he did
tonight
you're gonna go through some ups and
downs and um you know i think the staff
did a great job of kind of keeping
me level headed and kind of fighting
through it and you know
when it comes down to it it's still ball
and i i just love being out there again
it was it was fun to play
um you know unfortunately we just didn't
make enough plays
it looked like john gurdon had note
cards didn't it
he was like shuffling around note cards
like i i i
like talking points for his post game i
don't know wendy i never see a coach
with notes at a post game press
conference
he's got notes he should be he should be
used to it right
i mean this is essentially last year all
over again
i i don't know what you need i don't
know what you need to have in front of
you
because if you're because we've heard it
time and again
any time you ask a question of a coach
after a game that he doesn't know the
answer to
all you say is i have to watch the film
i have to watch the film
i have to watch the film then you that's
your easy way out you don't need notes
unless the notes say i have to watch the
film there's no reason to have the notes
anyway it was just kind of strange but
it wasn't strange to see mariota play
well i was happy for him
and i i was rooting for him to win i was
i mean we picked the raiders to win sims
and i didn't always want to be right
more than anything else
but it was it was just an entertaining
game it wasn't the best football it
wasn't the best decisions it wasn't the
best
clock management or not clock management
but place selection down near the goal
line
when the raiders were in position to get
that field goal in overtime
i i you know when you look at the
circumstance you have
them pinned in i don't know why you
don't go for the touchdown there and end
the game and never give them the ball in
a position where a touchdown beat you
via a kickoff
i'd rather give them the ball pinned in
deep on their own end
and maybe i get a short field and i get
to walk off field goal and win the game
so i it's easy to say it because it
didn't work out but it just got it just
got very uninspired
down near the goal line at least they
weren't running the quarterback every
play but it was josh jacobs josh jacobs
right after the the announcers put the
jinx on him saying oh josh jacobs wants
to end this game
all of a sudden josh jacobs can't gain a
yard yeah
and any time you start to get tie vibes
that the game is going to end in a tie
it's a pretty good
uh you know sign that they they both
teams kind of stink
and they're both getting in their own
way constantly and there were some big
tie
vibes going on when the raiders kicked
the field goal and you're like
maybe is anthony that actually is really
what i wanted to find out mike
would anthony lin have kicked a field
goal to tie the game
instead of trying to win a game as a
four and nine team
would he have if they had gotten into
field goal range and not
touched if they were not at the goal
line if they were at
let's say fourth and 12 at the 20-yard
line would he have kicked a field goal
instead of trying to win a game
that means absolutely nothing that at
this point would actually hurt your team
if you think you're going to be the head
coach next year
well i my first reaction when the
raiders kicked the field goal is they've
lost
just enough time for the chargers to
drive in position for michael bashley to
miss yet another field goal so yes he
would have tried the field goal
they would have missed it and they would
have lost anyway so i guess under that
analysis
throw it to the end zone try to win the
game because there's no way you're gonna
rely on your field goal kicker
to to tie the game even if your
motivation is to get a tie
and since they changed the rule a decade
ago
that takes away this sudden death
walk-off field goal victory
it's only the fourth time that we've had
first drive field goal
followed by a touchdown uh and they're
real you know one thing i noticed that
clock moves fast
in overtime with only 10 minutes they
changed it from 15 to 10 minutes a few
years ago when the buccaneers had to go
nearly a full 75 minutes and then they
had a thursday night game it was all
about
removing another argument against short
week football so they said well we
better make overtime
10 minutes in case somebody's playing on
a sunday that plays on a thursday we
don't want them to play 75 minutes and
then people are going to argue
your guys aren't sufficiently ready to
go again
that i you know i looked up first time i
noticed the clock in overtime there were
six minutes left
it's like holy crap i mean this may be
the situation we've talked about for a
few years
where if you play it right you can drive
down
and you can get that field goal and
there isn't enough time left for the
other team
to match it or beat it yeah yeah i know
the raiders had i mean they had to drive
like that at the end of the uh the
the third quarter sorry the end of third
quarter going to the fourth quarter
where they had the ball for about 10
10 minutes they did a good job with that
long drives
um i so college
college overtime is perfect college
overtime should be adopted by the nfl
everyone would love that and two the
circumstance you just described the
touch the field goal then touchdown
the total was at 51.5 anywhere from 51.5
to 53. so that touchdown mattered for a
lot of people
so that the fact that it only happens
like you know
has happened four times that's
impressive we've had that twice this
week
where we have uh kind of miraculous wins
or covers
or over unders so that's why people are
watching late mike that's why people are
watching overtime
on a game where neither teams go to the
playoffs and both coaches stick
this is why the nfl is looking into
expanding the total tv windows because
the betting the in-game betting
that's going to be revolutionized in in
fairly short order in the grand scheme
of things where you've got the real-time
images coming from the stadiums into
your home so you can bet between plays
and
the latency issue will be resolved you
have
games that you can focus on and people
can focus on and people can bet on and
they can stay engaged no matter what the
score is no matter what the broader
circumstances are
who cares if one team has no chance of
making at the playoffs who cares if both
teams have no chance
here it is on my tv i've got my phone
and i can have some fun and interact
with the game all game long up until
the very end hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports